welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Julius Stevens an assistant professor
of history at Yale University she is an
historian of modern South Asia and her
research focuses on how law has shaped
religion family and economy in colonial
and postcolonial South Asia and in the
wider Indian diaspora she teaches
courses on modern South Asia Islam
gender and colonialism today we talked
with professor Stevens about the book
manuscript she is currently working on
tentatively entitled governing Islam law
Empire and secularism in South Asia
welcome professor Stevens thanks for
having me on the show of course so let's
begin with a little overview of your
book tell us about it great so Marilyn
my book m is looking at the encounter
between colonial law and Islam in South
Asia what we today think of as Pakistan
India and Bangladesh what I'm trying to
do in the book is to both tell a story
about how the official system of
colonial law approaches this body of
religious law centered on Islam but then
the other thing I'm trying to do in the
book is to think about law more broadly
and to think about how law is being
debated and practices practice not just
in the official court system but also
outside the courts in newspaper columns
a lot of newspapers in colonial India
had a special column devoted to the
court system when trials were being held
crowds would gather outside the courts
waiting to hear the decision so there's
this enormous public interest I'm in the
law that I'm trying to bring in to the
field of legal history but then also
especially with Islamic law there
continues to be this really rich world
of what I call vernacular legal culture
in which in madrassas scholars are
debating topics related to Islamic law
issuing fatwas
pamphlets legal tracks so it's sort of
the book is tracing on these parallel
worlds of law and kind of out of that
kind of broader notion of the law I'm
telling I'm two entangled stories and so
the first is about what kind of happens
at the official level of the overarching
structures of the colonial legal system
and I argue in the book that colonial
law really frames religion in a new way
religion in general and Islam in
particular and the colonial legal system
has certain structures in place that
kind of do this work and one of the most
important of these is something called
religious personal law which basically
is how the legal system incorporates
religious laws so religious law is
administered through the colonial courts
but only in a really specific delineated
set of cases and this kind of box that's
put around religion by the law really
links it exclusively with cases
involving the family and cases involving
ritual practice and what I argue in the
book is that this kind of legal framing
basically strongly associates religion
with the family and particularly with a
family that's envisioned as traditional
patriarchal and also associate Sri
legend with irrational beliefs and
rituals that are considered to be kind
of impenetrable to kind of rational
thought and so that these particular
legal structures I argue are creating a
version of secularism that has a kind of
particular colonial genealogy so my book
is telling a story that is in some ways
a global story across the world in the
19th and 20th century religion is
merging as this kind of distinct social
category that is separate from secular
spheres like politics and
economy but what I'm showing on top of
that in the book is that there's a kind
of different genealogy of that process
that unfolds in a colonial context so in
metropolitan Britain the religious and
secular are also coming untangled but
the in the 19th century they continue to
be largely seen as compatible and that's
that's not true at least at the level of
official discourse in in colonial India
so that's the kind of overarching story
so you've told us about the more
official law that was going on can you
tell us a little bit about the
vernacular the more commonplace things
that were happening yeah great because I
think this is really a kind of important
part of the story because in a sense you
know I think law always has kind of
multiple sides of the story I mean if
you think about what happens in courts
different arguments by against each
other and so kind of by broadening the
range of law that I'm looking at what I
show is that when we turn to kind of the
everyday practice of law both inside and
outside the courts that this kind of
official narrative of binary division
between the religious and the secular
really breaks down and is disrupted and
in everyday practice and so what I'm
trying to do in the book is tell those
two stories of how you have this
overarching structure of binaries but
then when you turn to the kind of the
lived life of legal practice you have
this richer story that adds a lot of
complexity ok so can you give us a
specific example that showcases that and
yeah so I work with a lot of cases
involving marriages and officially
marriage is part of this domain of
religious personal law but when you have
a feuding couple come into court what
you often find is they're arguing about
their domestic arrangements the wife is
moved out the husband wants you to move
back in but they're also arguing about
their economic relationships about you
know whose monies is whose whose
property came from which side of the
family and so it's really both
and an economic dispute and when the
courts actually have to you know deal
with this particular couple they find it
much more difficult to actually totally
untangle religious laws from secular
laws governing things like debts and
contracts okay so in that in a
particular case what would actually
happen I mean what would be the outcome
yeah so the the courts officially you
know create a decision where they try to
still kind of parse ok this is the
religious aspects of the case this is
the economic aspects of the case I have
literally cases that get kind of divided
in half even though they involve a
single couple but then you know often
what actually happens to the couple is
more complex than that maybe they
actually end up resolving their dispute
outside the courts by bringing family
members in and that's where the kind of
story and the divide often gets
complicated right ok so what led you to
write the book so I think for a long
time I've been struck and and troubled
by the way in which Islam in kind of
popular perceptions both in South Asia
and in the u.s. tends to be portrayed
with a kind of repetitive set of troubs
so we're constantly bombarded with
images of Islam oppressing women we
encounter the words fanaticism and Islam
almost used as synonyms and what I
really wanted to do with this book is to
kind of think about those tropes more
historically because I think I'm kind of
seeing how they've evolved through the
process of history actually allows us to
kind of complicate and and question the
tropes that we kind of encounter in our
daily lives ok and how did you do the
research for the book so this was a
multi-site cited research project I did
a lot of work in archives in South Asia
and in the UK but i think the kind of
most fun and interesting part of my
research really was trying to find
sources that would speak to this
vernacular legal culture and to do that
i ended up traveling to a lot of smaller
libraries in south asia that had
specialized collections on islam and
urdu language materials and you know
often this is
small library but they're holding you
know the only copy of a book or
newspaper and so it's really you know a
great privilege to be able to work with
these materials which are also often in
very delicate condition but you know I
think also interestingly i also found a
decent amount of material online because
addresses and islamic organization some
of the texts i study still have a real
kind of life today in kind of ongoing
debates about islamic law so what was
your what was one of the more
interesting or surprising cases that you
came across so i think probably one of
the most fun set of cases that i worked
with was a series of cases involving
inheritance disputes within households
of prostitutes and you know prostitutes
don't actually often come up in the kind
of official record sometimes they hide
but they in colonial India actually some
of these women really have a very
significant amount of property and so in
the end to deal with that property they
do come into the legal records and so
you know in addition to having you know
raising really interesting questions
about the law you get this kind of
window into these alternative households
of women who are kind of set up their
family firm as a group of women working
in the sexual labor do you find that the
law is equitable toward women or is it
more biased towards males so I mean this
is a really common perception about
Islamic law that it is patriarchal but I
think if you think about the 19th
century in fact Islamic law provides a
far more protection of a married woman
can actually owned her own property
under Islamic law and that doesn't
happen until later in the 19th century
in the case of British women so in fact
you have Muslims who are saying look you
know our laws are actually more
progressive when you think about gender
equality and certainly in terms of
property that's I think a very strong
argument
and your book is very innovative in a
certain way let's talk about that um
yeah so I think I'm trying to innovate
it at two levels one about methodology
and the other about kind of an argument
and in terms of methodology you know and
I talked about this a little bit before
it's really trying to bring together two
stories that have been told by other
scholars as really separate one so on
the one hand telling a story about
colonial law and colonial governance but
on the other hand it's looking at kind
of the intellectual and cultural life of
Muslims and in South Asia and I think
when you bring those two stories
together and look at how they're
interacting really interesting things
happen but in terms of the argument you
know there's a whole kind of world of
scholarship about secularism out there
but both in the in most the scholarship
as well as in kind of popular
understandings of secularism we really
think about it as something that first
evolved in Europe and then only later
kind of got exported to Asia the Middle
East but what I'm trying to show in the
book is that actually particular
variants of secularism emerged first and
in their most exaggerated form in fact
in this colonial context oh very
interesting and then ultimately what do
you conclude in your book yeah so I
think you know by basically looking at
how these binaries are historically
constructed I'm making a whole range of
arguments intervening with the
scholarship on South Asia and on Islamic
law about issues of chronology about how
we understand certain Islamic legal
concepts but I think today actually what
might be more helpful to talk about is
kind of what I think my book is saying
to a more general public I think what
i'm showing is that a lot of the ways
that we think about islam actually
emerged through a specific history of
colonialism and that if we understand
that history we can actually start to
think outside of the ways in which Islam
and secularism often positioned in a
binary relationship of opposition
and interestingly you know in an hour's
so I'm actually going into the classroom
to teach my last class in a course on
political Islam and you know I think
really this comes out in my teaching as
well that I'm trying to get students to
see the ways in which you know they have
been grown up in an environment in which
Islam and the West are often you know
spoken about as these two separate and
opposing entities but as a historian
what I try to show them is that Islam is
hugely internally diverse and the West
is hugely internally divorced French
people in Americans understand
secularism in really profoundly
different ways and then when we
appreciate that internal diversity we
start to see Islam in the West not as
locked in a kind of timeless
relationship of opposition but having
had this very complex in varied set of
mutual entanglements very good thank you
so much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work great Thank
You Marilyn for more information about
professor Stevens and her research
please visit our website at yale edu
slash macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale